We have to be clear: the world has never been
better than it is right now.
Thanks mostly to globalization there are less
and less wars, global poverty is falling markedly
and quality of life is generally improving.
This is obviously not happening in a uniform
way across all countries, but it is true from
a global perspective.
However, and against all odds, many western
countries have decided to rebel and refuse
openness and understanding among their nations.
In Europe, for example, extreme right-wing
parties are spreading uncertainty: Le Pen
in France, Wilders in the Netherlands, and
Hofer in Austria are good examples of this
new wave which has also reached countries
like Finland, Denmark, Germany and Hungary,
among others.
Further, it has also been partly responsible
for the Brexit victory in the United Kingdom.
It is a movement which is taking advantage
of fear, despite the fact that we are living
in societies which are becoming safer and
safer.
But, as you all know, these ideas are not
exclusive to Europe.
Donald Trump won the US election and has spoken
about his views which are clearly contrary
to globalisation and immigration.
At this point the best question we can ask
is: Are there any developed countries left
who still believe in open borders and globalisation?
Well, there are.
And today we are going to look at one of the
most significant of these countries.
-CANADA’S OPENNESS-
In the year 2016, Canada has admitted into
their country more than 300,000 new immigrants.
That is close 1% of its total population.
This is a greater proportion than any other
large developed country
And note here that this is not something that
is new, the measure has been in force for
more than two decades.
The result of this, today, one in every five
Canadians was born abroad, a percentage which
is almost double that of the US or the UK.
And, truth be told, this hasn’t led to any
national tragedy, in fact, quite the contrary.
And Canadians are the first to know this.
According to the prestigious Environics Institute,
most citizens (almost 80% of them) consider
immigration to be good for the economy and
that it represents the best way to deal with
important issues such as it ageing population.
If you think about it, this does make sense:
Employment is the country's most productive
asset, so, why should they prevent it from
growing?
In the context of a dynamic economy, what’s
the harm of immigrants who are willing to
work, set up companies, or get an education?
It is, we think, something good.
-TRUDEAU’S FIRST YEAR-
In October 2015, Justin Trudeau became Canada’s
Prime Minister after defeating, against all
odds, the conservative Stephen Harper, who
had held office for almost ten years.
Since then, the political agenda has been
dominated by a determination to deepen the
country’s pro-globalisation policies.
Trudeau himself, a left-winger, has become
quite an advocate of promoting free trade
and social mobility.
In his first year in office he signed a free
trade agreement with the European Union and
confirmed Canada’s adherence to TPP.
Although Trump’s first action was to destroy
it, it was meant to be the biggest commercial
agreement in history.
In just a year Canada built up free trade
relationships with almost 60% of world’s
economy.
And Trudeau wants to expand this further,
and increase trade with China.
And the government is doing more of the same
concerning immigration.
They have even set the goal of increasing
the number of immigrants they receive by 50%
every year.
Given these principles, it shouldn’t surprise
you to hear that Canada is one of the most
committed countries when making things easy
for Syrian refugees.
Canada has received more than 33,000 Syrians
since Trudeau became Prime Minister.
In his first year, Trudeau himself personally
went to Toronto’s airport to welcome them
into the country.
-MIGRATION POLICY-
But wait!
Immigration in Canada is not free.
It’s more regulated than we at VisualPolitik,
would like.
But, what is important here, is not whether
there are, or are not, excessive administrative
requirements, but that citizens shouldn’t
automatically view as criminals those who
come to work or live in other countries.
And this is precisely why Canada is quite
so successful - they are a country which takes
pride in looking for additional citizens,
not temporary immigrants.
Since 1967, admission has been based on a
points system which considers qualification,
experience, professional skills, or knowledge
of English or French.
In the same way, this system also gives priority
to those professionals needed by companies.
The
tendency seems to be to make these procedures
easier.
But what is important is the social recognition
and the integration of immigrants into the
country.
The Canadian Bill of Rights itself recognizes
the concept of multicultural patrimony.
There are solid policies to encourage integration
which, by the way, usually encourage the newcomers
not to lose their own cultural identity and
consider diversity an enriching factor.
For example, in Canadian schools, it is easy
to find classes taught in Spanish or Ukrainian.
The results support these policies indeed:
in the last decade, Canada’s growth has
been bigger than the US, Germany or the UK,
and a high standard of living exists in the
country.
Now it might be easier to understand why Canada’s
immigration website collapsed few hours after
Trump’s victory was known.
Or why there were front covers of the Economist
highlighting Canada’s liberty.
Of course Canada´s model isn’t perfect.
But compared to the new nationalist and populist
tendencies of other countries, Canada shows
how desirable openness alternative really
is.
The key takeaway here is to try to make things
better instead of isolating your country from
the rest of the world - the latter of which
is an argument that other politicians like
Trump are defending.
Well, now it’s your turn: Do you think immigration
generates as many problems as some claim?
Would you rather live in an open and diverse
society like Canada?
We will be waiting for your answers and, please,
if you haven’t yet subscribed to VisualPolitik,
you can do so by clicking the logo on the
screen now!
We´d also ask you to click the “like”
button if you enjoyed this alternative to
some of Trump’s policies.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video!